to Afghanistan now where at least 19
people have been killed after a suicide
bomber targeted an education center in
Kabul students were taking part in a
test to prepare for their University
entrance exams the attack happened in an
area of the capital where many people
from the Hazara minority live hazar is a
predominantly Shia Muslim group and
they're often targeted because of their
race and religious practices
for more on this let's bring in look
fuller shurzai who joins us from Kabul
he's on the phone what more do we know
about what happened
the exploded happened around 7 30 Kabul
time in a education center industrated
Hazard a minority Place area mostly
hazardas go to this Educational Center
this happened when the students were
going for a conquer examination mock
test which is a university or college
entry test
according to eyewitnesses the suicide
attacker first killed the guard in front
of the educational center and then went
inside and definited his explosives
according to
the spokesperson of Kabul Police
Department the number of casualties are
around 19 and 27 others were injured in
this two-side attack
has anyone climbed responsibility yet
not yet and none of the groups have
claimed any responsibility of these
attack on the hazarama energy
all right thank you very much for the
update
who is joining us on the phone from
Kabul let's bring in FaZe Zealand from
Kabul now he's a professor of political
science at Kabul University
Faye thanks so much for being on the
program what's the current security
situation across Afghanistan at the
moment
uh thanks for having me uh the security
situation across Afghanistan is slowly
uh and rapidly deteriorating things are
not getting as it was planned and
expected from the Takeover of Taliban
over the country we see and we witness a
small skirmishes around the country
specifically and north of uh Kabul and
north of Afghanistan and in central
Afghanistan today's blast was a genius
Act of
terrorism and it was
considered one of the deadliest in past
few weeks in past one year I think we
had several such attacks where
minorities
religious
different groups were attacked and also
or Target killing we have been
witnessing there are so many prominent
religious Scholars from different
religions groups have been targeted
in
total we can say that Afghanistan is
collapsing once again through its very
economic political and security
situations
so what you're saying is is that there
has been a significant rise in attacks
targeting Shia and other minorities
since the Taliban took power more than a
year ago
let's not simplify it's not only the
sheer minority there are attacks on
different
different groups of uh
Afghanistan even Taliban themselves have
been targeted The prominent Scholars
have been killed in past few months
who was a prominent Taliban
religious scholar he was targeted and
recently last Last Friday the year was a
blast in front of uzirajan mask where
many
Taliban and Ordinary People they go for
Friday prayers and it is fully
Sunni mask no Shia minorities last
Friday so it is some kind of general and
security
incidents since the Taliban have taken
over as they do not have the capacity of
counter-terrorism
encounter Insurgency they have been
transitioning themselves from being
military to a government power so it may
take time to take control fully of the
security apparatus looking at this
specific incident today it was in an
area where a lot of Hazara minority live
why would they be the target of an
attack like this
it is very unfortunate I think for the
past many years on these specific
occasions where the entry exams have
been taken place at such a school is
such failing areas
have been targeted by Suicide attacks in
past many years such attacks were taken
responsibility by the Isis and they have
claimed
blowing such areas it is it seems the
same Trend it seems the same kind of
attack which has happened in past few
years and it is very very unfortunate
that you are losing our very bright
Minds specifically children's and kids
and such attacks indeed that's a very
good point to make all right thank you
very much Zeland a professor of
political science at Kabul University
thank you